oh my god it's a set full of black
people like the other day like they were
all just somebody said something
everybody harmonized hi i'm burgundy
baker this is antoinette robertson and
i'm margaret avery and this is terrell
and i'm golden brooks i'm gary anthony
williams i'm the fifth tallest actor in
america and this is who's who
[Music]
i really do think that she's close to
her character because the character is
caring
and wants to please her mama grandmama
in person i think she's very sweet and
caring and she looks out for me for
whatever reason and i feel very very
thankful for that if blue nell was an
uber driver
lunelle is lunelle
no i'm saying lunell is gonna loot nail
anything up yeah i would say lunell is
most like her character you know them
nails is in every
that's my girl
no it's my crush
who's most likely to freak out and
laughter in the middle of the scene
i want to say me only because most of my
scenes are with antoinette and she's
she's mad in character honestly so he
might she's yeah i mean
it's funny things happening that people
don't be saying on set so see
he gonna break up that smoke
yeah
hmm 100
100 yeah i think so she laughs all the
time i do
terrell
you gonna say that me
really yeah you can just sleep in anyway
yeah
who would fall asleep on saturday it
would fall asleep i'm gonna give it to
monk then just because i don't want it
i don't want it i mean who wants to be
deemed a narcoleptic dj d-nuts
yeah yeah he came up and did me for me
and i almost seriously went dude just
play my part yeah he's good he's great
yeah oh that's for sure gary funny
that's going to gary yeah he's hard the
class he's the impression
yeah that's class impressionist you
can't top uncle right you can't you
can't you can't gary definitely got that
that's it hands down felonious he's
hilarious did terrell say felonious too
he plays the dj yeah yeah dj nuts and he
really is funny
oh margaret margaret
and what people don't know is she's
always willing to give advice
she will tell you everything you need to
know she's been in the game for a long
time i'm grateful yeah to have her
around like she's she's awesome a legend
and just wise
[Music]
i don't think anyone
forgets their lines i think we just come
up with our own stuff oh that's true oh
that is true that's the difference
that's the difference yeah i'll be on
mine i'll be on my team
next
me
yeah
it could be
oh my god it's a set full of black
people
i think it happened
like the other day like they were all
just somebody said something everybody
harmonized well you know we all black
folks we just yeah i mean yeah we got
broken out to a couple of the spirituals
a while ago somebody said the word rain
on say and then we heard can you stand
the rain
rain by swb yes rain down
it was late at night the other night
started raining a little bit everybody i
did my little rain dance yeah because we
danced and we sing when you know it's
going up it's a black party that's what
it is
thank you buzzfeed i i feel like not
only did i learn about myself
uh in that game i feel like i learned so
much
about burgundy
i've now transferred most of my accounts
into her name
thanks for that thank you buzzfeed that
was so much fun definitely had a good
time kicking it with golden make sure
you go check out block party
that contraption is not made for black
women
[Music]
you